son âge avancé bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors jusqu'ici
a désigné comme un allié précieux la
turquie serait désormais un problème
pour l'otan ankara at il toujours sa
place au sein des mots des pays membres
de l'alliance selon vous personnellement
je dirais que qui ne devrait pas avoir
sa place dans l'otan
malheureusement le texte l'alliance
atlantique ne permet pas d'exclure un
membre qui ne respectent pas ces règles
donc je crois que l'otan est pris à son
propre piège et ne peut pas se
débarrasser du problème turc comme elle
longtemps ce qui explique qu'un
secrétaire général de l'otan et d'un
discours depuis des mois tellement calme
pacifier lycée et qui n'aboutit à rien
le point de non retour a été atteint
selon vous il y à une offensive en serre
et les forages en méditerranée orientale
la suspicion de violation de l'embargo
sur les armes les arbres également à
destination de la libye et l'implication
dans le haut-karabagh et puis encore
hier c'est cette prise de parole
comptera emmanuel macron non on dépeint
un point de non retour nous connaissons
les diplomates les diplomates eux feront
tout pour que tous finissent par
s'arranger
nous sommes dans un rapport de forces au
moins verbale diplomatique où chacun
avance ses pions pour tenir un résultat
maintenant vous n'avez pas évoqué quand
même c'était celle du s 400 acheté par
la turquie veut iliad spacek a eu lieu
il ya deux jours et qui a aussi suscité
de profondes anneaux des stations de la
part des états unis
actuellement air de ran attaquent sur
tous les fronts
il est sur cinq fronts militaires il
respecte pas ces accords ou ceux de
l'alliance au sein de l'otan c'est quand
même quelqu'un qui se sont
messieurs chauvin si je ne vous entends
plus je les ai continué bien je côté du
donc je ne sais pas où j'en étais mais
peu importe on s'aperçoit qu'à dogan est
quelqu'un qui ne cesse de provoquer des
conflits
ils ne cessent d'utiliser son arme et ne
cesse d'insulter ses alliés c'est
quelqu'un qui quand même devient un
personnage dangereux en méditerranée au
sein de l'otan et à ses frontières
il va bien fou justement quelle quelle
solution au problème
voilà peut apporter l'otan comment est
ce qu'elle peut régler le problème
turque selon vous l'otan a montré
qu'elle n'était pas capable de le risque
maintenant dans les solutions ne faut
pas donner des postes de responsabilité
au turc au sein de l'alliance
ensuite il ne faut pas d'associer à des
manoeuvres militaires
il faut que tous les alliés de l'otan
accepte cette mise à l'écart de la
turquie c'est à dire que la turquie doit
être mise à l'écart au sein de l'otan
jusqu'à ce qu'elle ait compris elles
doivent se plier à un l'ensemble des
décisions de l'alliance aujourd'hui la
turquie est un ennui pour l'otan et
c'est en u doit être résolu déjà en la
mettant à l'écart
la turquie ne doit plus être soucier un
certain nombre d'actions de l'otan et
quelles qu'elles soient les conséquences
pour l'otan si jamais
elle se séparait de la turquie c'est
vrai que là on est un petit peu dans la
prospective
mais honnêtement qu'est ce que nous
apporte la turquie aujourd'hui au sein
de l'otan la russie n'est pas comme un
50 m c'est un avis personnel je suis
certain que d'autres états ne
partagerait pas la même position
donc là la russie n'est pas un ennemi
principal ensuite va déjà retirons les
états majors et les différents armements
que nous avons en turquie de telle façon
que l'action qui valent reste son monde
eurasiatique à la frontière de l'europe
alors les conséquences
oui on pourra toujours dire que la
turquie représente la deuxième armée de
l'otan après des états unis pour
l'instant on constatons que 4 1 l s'agit
beaucoup
elle se déploie je ne changerai a des
petits problèmes de liaison avec
françois chavance y est en tout cas
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'ifri l'institut
français de relations internationales
experts en géostratégie